самості ваша панель шаїш щиро дякую шоу
чи знаєш шанс для інтерв'ю дочка його чи
роздрукувати хотіла б з чого ворс ніж
може ви назвати і трек кращі результати
візиту as the new місії МВФ до прикрасили
почнуть повік не
фокусом ванна не щось золото я
сконцентруйся на одній кримінальній
виставку та кіль кофту себе на них
харчуватися втомимося квітня до ключові
результат що ми досягли результати на
експертному рівні представлені до ми у
ряду україни продовжить і переліт
програми розширеного фінансування c
дізналася чим у пілота йому зрушення для рада
directory мвф ще до виділення транші до
тут теж
ваше днк велика в Україні часто
самий мвф виношую ризиком упить вийшов
не ціна нас для населення по pro 1000
уряд неодноразово заявляв щоб
оновити великі ніші ви магів мвф яко
ваша doom кашу досьє ініціативи києва та
що фонд раді в Україні для Петра
та найбідніших версту населення одеси під
for the people
ми поважаємо ще з навіть гарне рішення
правильне рішення рахунок поїдаючи кулі тис
і
якому Петро і мого у 2014 році сиріт
пенсії у моїй значний дефіцит бюджету
нафтогазу ще й великим щільно компа
дотки олл-ін або українські споживачі
викручувати над те багато енергією
крем натовп передні системі був і
проблеми з управлінням c було
несправедлива система ще субсидію валу
адже на і багатші будинки держави за
пропана система зміню пінхед геть
апарат велика пара хіт до субсидії а
не позбавить їх хтось на ідиші вимагатиме ринку
шляхом досвіду не і я наляканий і результати
овочі багата накласти труби ти ще б
порожні з механізмом на путик з робота
найефективнішим виправданим топ то
щоб ті, хто дійство вимагатиме субсидій
відривала їх ct
чим і так вже чомусь бачати дали горем
привід самості нашого т.д.
я до вашої завалено відтінку процесу
реформам в Україні
віку з них на та на чердаці triforce як я
вже за ті, що знали ось чим мало було
зрубане за для макроекономічної
стабілізації теж на хіба вкрай важливі
вас брехт і результати дуся нами яку
фіскальний так і в макроекономічній
політики ми так вже з великого вчинку
фінансовому секторі і нбу посилань я kno
році та функції таки регуляторну
політику і великого і патча
визначать і великим банком ще довго та
годину на рубався ми побачили значний
прогрес в енергетиці засіків esp
одягаємось
щебрикін дефіцит бюджету нафтогазу не в
доу я буду покритої тієї за голом ми
вашому знач не результати в психології c
складні процес із чеджу мало накласти
рубає і вони до 71 загрожують далі
хочемо у батчата щодо вливання процесу
реформ я ж київ призначив кут і фібру
без корупції діяльності національного
антикорупційного бюро
а також кулі тэц і рахунку
антикорупційних заходив на приклад
реформу вони державних під спадщину та
приватизації віку будуть дуже важливими
момент
сау від села та економічний прогноз мвф на
2016 Ерік для України чи можна його
повели зрощення ввп дтп
запас фільмом втомимося ними мереж і ми
пішли по вільно видно плані економіки та
c вигляд образи лося на ввп producing
густа промислового руб дитинства та зростання
drip на трахея
замшевого боку цик ривка та зрощення
тому хлопчикові йому
з великими ввп тих уроку позбавлена ​​pewter а
вид сотка
я також хочу опинитися на 1000 за
зовнішнім середовищем ще дасін з приємного і
діти просто винесені я кіт vortice
сільгосп продукції металі в засіки
стали перші проблеми у торгівлі
сонячний відразу вощини спрею та потужному
побачила нюк так вже зриваючи покращення у
фінансовому секторі
ще ось цю ситуації коли банки ми можемо
видавати нові кредити
звідки ваші шкарпетки і вил і каїна roser
мова дефолту
українські уретру б мало для того, щоб
ліквіду ват та значення фінансової
дисбаланс і солідним щоб лора
структурована державний борг процес
тривав кілька місяців, а лазери що
успішно завершився тарик писати про вас та
помітив ще стабільність системи
державних фінансів в Україні
значно зросла заводжу його вона так вже
важлива його на рази продовжу ось і вид по
видно фіскальну політику ми побачили
які сну і в занурення бюджету і гарний і
фіскальні результати у 2015 уроки у
хвала на і на 2016 це рік бюджет так вже
парою велика ви до найнятих параметрів
пройти говорив мвф теж важливо його щоб
фіскальна політика в середній рядок
проспект або було стабільніше це
одна з причин чому ми за іклами
українське уряд у знайду їх чому
майбутньому
простирадла обхідної пенсії на реформу та
таким чином
стабілізувати систему державних
фінансів носа самі було замінено панова
6 год радіо дещо означає і годину для
дочки
дякую